مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه في هذه الفقره نستضيف المحلل
العسكري اللواء فاز الدويري ونستعرض معه
مجريات اليوم ال74 للعدوان مرحبا بك سياده
اللواء وا اوولا مع محمود الكن نتابع عبر
الخريطه التفاعليه اخر
التطورات الميدانيه في اكثر من محور محمود
واكثر من جبهه صحيح حسن نحن بامكاننا
الحديث عن ثلاث محاور ومواضيع رئيسيه
الاول هنا في شمال الجبهه الشماليه وجنوب
لبنان نتحدث عن احداث رئيسيه حدثت اليوم
كتائب القدسم في لبنان ذكرت بانها استهدفت
مطار كريات شموه هنا في الشمال بنحو 12
صاروخا المطار يبعد عن كريات شموه باتجاه
الشرق نحو ك مر واحد ما نزال ضمن قواعد
الاشتباك اي التي هي محيط الخمس كيلومترات
او مدى الخمس كيلومترات الاستهدافات تكون
في هذا النطاق يضاف الى ذلك ان حزب الله
استهدف هنا د قال انه استهدف دبابه
ميركافا في موقع المالكيه موقع المالكيه
هو في هذه المنطقه نحو 18 را من كريات
شموه هذا بالنسبه للجبهه الشماليه الان
نتوجه الى قطاع غزه هنا في قطاع غزه
جبهت رئيسيتان لكن الحدث الابرز هو نشاهده
باللون الاصفر يبدو ان سياسات التوغل
الاسرائيليه بدات تاخذ شكلا اخر في
المناورات لماذا نقول ذلك لان هذه المناطق
الصفراء بدات تظهر في التوغل في المنطقه
الوسطى او في وسط القطاع نتحدث عن مسافه
تبلغ حوالي كيل متر و300 متر او كيل متر
ونصف وهذا ايضا نشاهد امتداد في الشجاعيه
نحو كيلومتر و300 متر على كامل هذا الشريط
هنا بسبب سياسه التوغل هذه يبدو انها
تتطابق سياسيا مع ما
تذكره القياده السياسيه لقوات الاحتلال
بانها تريد ابقاء شريط عازل في المنطقه
ربما قد يقرا بهذا التفسير بهذا الاتجاه
خاصه و ان هذه المنطقه الصفراء اتسعت كما
ذكرنا هذا بالنسبه لشمال قطاع غزه لكن
ماذا عن
الجنوب هنا في الوسط هذا هو التمدد الذي
ذكرناه هذه هي النقطه نحن نتحدث عن شرق
البريج اذا توجهنا جنوبا الى خان يونس
هنالك قوه الدفع الاسرائيليه في التوغل
تاتي من محورين رئيسيين هنا في الشمال
شارع كيسوفيم
القرار
والتجمعات تجمعات الاليات ما تزال في هذه
النقاط ما يزال التوغل يراوح مكانه تقريبا
في هذه النقطه يضاف الى ذلك المنطقه
الجنوبيه من محورين
رئيسيين هنا في الفخاري باتجاه خان يونس
لكن لا تطويق لبني سيله حتى اللحظه لا
تدعم المصادر المفتوحه وصور الاقمار
الصناعيه التي سنراها بعد قليل في 15ش من
ديسمبر بان بني سهيله طوقت او خانيونس
طوقت لماذا نقول ذلك هذه مواقع لصور
الاقمار الصناعيه باللون الاحمر لتجمع
الاليات سنشاهد اندفاع من عبسان الكبيره
هنا تمركز الاليات الرئيسيه ايضا هنا من
عبسان الصغيره بهذه النقطه هذه المنطقه
الجنوبيه
لدفع التوغل الاسرائيلي والدبابات يضاف
الى ذلك ما تزال تراوح مكانها عند شارع
جمال عبد الناصر وهو من شاركي سفيم محور
صلاح الدين وهذا الاندفاع باتجاه مدينه
حمد الاليات كانت في هذه النقاط وهذا ما
سنناقشه سنناقشه معكما حسن واللواء فايز
التوه الاسرائيلي وص ممود سنبدا بما ذكرته
عن ذلك الشريط العازل الذي تحاول اسرائيل
ان تخلقه على حدود مناطق غلاث غزه اي
سياده اللواء يعني على الرغم من محاوله
توسيع هذا الشريط العازل لكن عمليات
المقاومه مستمره داخله كما هو واضح وكذلك
ما زالت تنطلق الصواريخ من اي مكان وما
زالت تصل الى تل ابيب صفارات الانذار في
تل ابيب والملايين الى الملاجئ من جديد
يعني الان نتوقف عند القصف الصاروخي نعم
بعد انقطاع لعده ايام جاء الان القصف
الصاروخي وهذا يحمل اي عده مضامين سياسيه
وعسكريه من اهم المضامين السياسيه عندما
نتحدث عن اطلاق صواريخ على وسط فلسطين
المحتله مطار
الليد فيما يتعلق في محيط او في تلبيب
الكبرى جنوب شرق الى غير ذلك نتحدث ان من
يعطي الاشاره لاطلاق هذه الصواريخ يجب ان
تكون مستوى سياسي لماذا لان تداعياتها
ورسائلها اكبر من البعد العسكري اها الان
بما ان هناك قناه و و قائمه موثوقه متمكنه
ما بين المستوى السياسي والمستوى العسكري
من قمه المستوى العسكري حتى المنفذ في
الميدان هذا له يحمل عده مضامين اولا
البعد السياسي ارتى ان يتم اطلاق هكذا او
حلل ارتا ان يطلق الصواريخ متى بعد 24
ساعه من زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي الذي
كان موقفه واضحا جدا من الاستمرار في دعم
اسرائيل ومن الحديث عن ما بعد حماس فارادت
حماس من خلال القياده السياسيه وتنفيذ
العسكري ان تقول انا موجود انا قادر على
اتخاذ القرار واطلق صواريخ متى واين وكيف
اشاء ما زالت موجوده القياده والسيطره ما
زالت موجوده بمستويات الاربعه وليس بال
المستوى الاول والثاني طيب سياده اللواء
لدينا الان صور للاقمار الصناعيه لمناطق
التوغل الاسرائيليه ايه لا سما
اي هذه المناطق ما لجنوب خان يونس محاوله
توغل الاسرائيليه في في هذه الم هذه في في
15 شهر قبل عده ايام وبالتالي هي تبين
نقاط التجمع وهذا المنظر اعتدنا عليه في
صور الاقمار الصناعيه التي عرضت مرارا
وتكرارا واضح الش موضوع الدبابات يعني اين
اين تتم ن هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه اولا
لاحظ المسافه البينيه ما بين ال البيوت
وبالتالي تستطيع ان تجد العديد من الساحات
تتوقف بها هذه الاليات تنشئ سواتر ترابيه
لانه هذه الاليات حركتها مرتبطه بحركه
الاليات اللي امامها طيب لنشاهد ايضا اي
الان صور لشمال خ خانيونس ايضا صور اقمار
الصناعيه قبل ان ننتقل الى فيديو لسرايا
القدس يا سيدي نفس نفس الوضع هذا يمثل
تموضع القوات قبل اربعه ايام ولكن يعني لا
توجد صور حديثه لكن هذا لا يقدم الكثير
هذا يبين صوره الموجات اللاحقه من القوات
العامله في هذه المنطقه القوات العامله
تقع في الامام وهذه القوات تتوقف نتيجه
تعثر حركه القوات الاماميه طيب اي لا ادري
ان كنا نستطيع الان مشاهده اي الشجاعيه
ايضا حي الشجاعيه
ل نعم هذا في حي الشجاعيه شرق مدينه غزه
تقريبا نفس الام اي نفس نفس الاماكن اللي
تحدثنا عنها قبل عده ايام لا تغيير عليها
نتحدث عن شارع بغداد شارع شارع المنصوره
نفس الاماكن يعني خطوط الاشتباك لا تزال
موجوده هي هي ذات فيديو سرايا
القدس هذا الفيديو وزعته سرايا القدس و
يعني استخدام مدافع الهاون واطلاق قذائف
قذائف الهاون اكثر من مره شاهدنا لقطات
مماثله
وتقريبا هذا لاحظ هو من خلف جذار هذا هذا
الاستهداف لقوات الاحتلال في شرق خان يونس
الان هذا هذا مداه يصل في بعض الحالات الى
7.5 كر يختلف حتى الهاون الذي لدى القسام
مدا يختلف عن الهاون لانه كل هندسه عكسيه
من قبل الاطراف وبالتالي مواصفاته مختلفه
العيار 120 ملم يستخدم ضد مناطق تجمع
القوات المعاديه وضد الاهداف الليله
والرخو طيب كان كان بودنا لو هناك مزيد من
الوقت لنتحدث اكثر عن كل هذه المعطيات لكن
انتهى وقتنا شكرا اللواء فيز دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ونعود الان الى عبد
القادر